hello everyone and welcome to one of the
best games from round eight that I've
decided to cover it is Andrea speno
versus Vincent kimer both of them so far
without a loss and it's already round
eight so it's very very commendable and
the the game itself is incredibly
complicated and what's uh what's most
incredible about it is that um yeno for
the first like 15 moves spent zero time
on the clock he played all of his moves
instantly when in fact it was Vincent
who chose very very rare line minds but
for some reason either yeno really knew
what Vincent will prepare for this game
or he's just so well versed and he knows
everything that he was able to play so
quickly uh so let's check it out yeno
has the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 uh he goes for theti
opening we have Knight to F6 and now
Pawn to C4 okay transposing into the
English for those of you who like to see
photos here's even a photo of them
playing uh there we have it
uh very nice uh also in in the
background you can see Vladimir FV
playing his game against PR the two of
them have drawn their game uh but
getting back to this game uh we have
Pawn to E6 and now Pawn to G3 uh
countering the ainur defense by fian
doing the light squore Bishop we have D5
Bishop to G2 and now standard moves here
are Bishop D7 and D captures on C4
Vincent goes for Pawn to D4 okay not
incredibly rare it's only the fifth most
popular continuation we have castles and
now almost exclusively C5 is played here
but Vincent goes for Knight to C6 and
okay Pawn to E3 we have Pawn to E5 e
captures on D4 and now Vincent plays
Pawn to E4 advances um the pawn attacks
the Knight and uh again it has been
reached Knight to G5 has been played
here it's the only move that's ever been
played here is the top move recommended
by the engine but yeno plays Pawn to D5
and it is now as of move eight that we
have a completely new game now I was
very much interested in this position so
I of course allowed the engine to Crunch
the numbers and the engine says as the
engine always does that the position is
0.0 or maybe maybe black will be even
slightly better so it's very very
strange that yeno chooses such a line
but not really as Vincent is a human
being so he might make a mistake uh so
okay e captures on F3 now you can't
capture the Knight as Pawn captures
Bishop on G2 so you have to play Queen
captures on F3 and now Knight to E5
attacking um Andre's Queen we have Rook
to E1 pinning the Knight and now uh you
can't um play just anything here because
D4 is coming and you're going to have to
give the piece back so you play
something like Knight D7 uh then D4 is
very strong D captures and E5 is coming
and the White's Position will just be
incredible also if you try something
like Bishop D7 you just try giving back
the piece again it's not great just
captures King goes to cast and now Pawn
to D4 again White's position is
absolutely incredible here but Queen to
E7 the move inant play that is the move
you have to find because now uh the
threat is Queen captures on F3 the
Knight is no longer pinned so Andre goes
back Queen to D1 and now Bishop to G4
piling up on the White Queen Pawn to F3
and now Bishop captures on F3 idea being
of course that if Bishop captures Knight
captures comes with check and if you
capture then Queen captures un one
happens so after Bishop captures on F3
Queen to A4 with check and this is now
the real question what does Vincent play
here all of the moves here were
instantly played by Andre and Vincent
already burned half of his time pretty
much and the point is if you block with
the Knight let's say you go Knight F to
D7 then D4 comes and then let's say you
Castle Queen side the problem is also
the A7 Pawn is undefended so let's say
you go Knight to C3 Queen to F6
unpinning so now you have to capture
back the piece and let's say Bishop to
C5 check to defend the A7 pawn bishop to
E3 Bishop captures on E3 Rook captures
Queen to B6 will put pressure on The
Rook on E3 let's say Rook 8 E1 and now
finally Knight Will capture on E5 but
now you'll play Queen to B3 and uh at
the end of this line white will maybe be
slightly better nothing spectacular
let's say Bishop captures Queen captures
on B6 a captures Rook captures on E5 and
now the bishop escapes and now you uh
lift The Rook over to E upgrading it to
to a pig so Rook to D7 defends the pawn
and so on you play this game equal
material black has a double B Pawn it's
a bishop against the Knight so maybe
white slightly better but nothing um
nothing to uh count on uh so it's
possible but Vincent goes the other way
he plays King to d8 um you could also
maybe block first but King to d8 will
have to be played even if you block with
the queen and give up the Knight with
check King to d8 will have to be played
so Vincent starts with that and now we
have Pawn to D4 finally Andre goes after
the Knight Bishop captures on G2 Rook
captures on E5 attacks the queen and now
Queen to D7 this is how Vincent um uh
plays it out and now he will also win
the exchange because if the queen moves
then the bishop just escapes via the H3
Square so you have to trade here Queen
captures sorry Queen captures on D7
Knight captures attacks The Rook on E5
and once uh now you can't move the Rook
the bishop again escapes so King cap on
G2 Knight captures on E5 and D captures
on E5 and this is the position that yeno
got out of the opening and it's a very
strange one look at this uh total and
complete undevelopment by black and by
white so none of the pieces are in the
game and white has this massive Center
so definitely a position you don't
encounter on a daily basis and Vincent
says all right now it's time to
undermine that strong Center and also if
you count the pieces Vincent is just up
the exchange he has two Rooks and a
bishop whereas Andre has a rook Knight
and Bishop so okay he tries to undermine
the pawn chain F6 Pawn to
E6 uh we have Pawn to C6 and now Bishop
to F4 C captures C captures on D5 and
Rook to C8 slowly but surely developing
his pieces Knight to C3 and Bishop to B4
we have Knight to E4 now with control
over the D6 Square so one thing you
don't want to allow is the pawn to land
on D6 if the pawn lands on D6 then you
know it's pretty much over maybe you can
defend but it's going to be it's going
to be hell so Rook to C4 now attacking
the Knight and here we have King to F3
just defending the Knight and now the
only way to keep playing this is King to
E7 to stop Pawn to D6 but um Vincent
tried Rook to D4 as this also uh gives
him control over the D6 square but it
also allows um Andre to just win the
game on the spot but it's a very
difficult move to spot and uh well it's
not a very difficult if you know what
move wins the game pretty much every
game so I've already said too much feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for Andrea speno uh while I give you a
couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting this uh inevitable idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course P B4 but not right
away first we have to prepare it it's
paon to A3 paon to A3 as it allows us to
play Pawn to B4 but not only that uh
what do you do with the bishop the
problem is you cannot go here this is
guarded by the bishop and by the Knight
if you go to E7 then D6 comes with Tempo
so you cannot allow that then the bishop
moves then E7 comes with Tempo you
cannot go to f8 because then again D6
comes with tempo as you are threatening
E7 with check to win material so what
can you do if you play Knight Bishop to
A5 then the problem is Knight to D6
threatening this for Fork this will Fork
the king and the Rook threatening this
Fork this will threaten the rook and the
bishop and of course if you avoid both
of these forks with King to E7 then you
run into a third fork with Knight to F5
check and you blunder The Rook so how
can you play this it's uh uh very very
hard if not impossible Vincent tries
Rook to D3 check this will avoid the
third Fork that we've just covered in
this hypothetical line King to G2 and
now Bishop to A5 and okay Knight to D6
still King to E7 Knight to F5 with check
now Andre will repeat the position once
King to d8 Knight to D6 check King E7
Knight to F5 check King to d8 and now
Pawn to D6 now uh well uh D7 is a threat
E7 is a threat what can Vincent play
here Vincent plays Pawn to G5 to kick
away the Bishop from uh defending the
pawn and from such a strong diagonal
Bishop to E3 now attacks A7 and now he
plays Rook to E8 puts pressure on the E6
pawn and sort of invites this Pawn to
come forward and it's better to have um
when you're def defending and your
opponent has a dark Square Bishop it's
better to force his pawns and dark
squares because if you have pawns and
light squares and you have a dark Square
Bishop to operate in between them it
will be a lot more dangerous so E7 check
King to D7 and now Bishop captures on A7
and now remember when I said Pawn to B4
was the winning idea but you have to
prepare it with Pawn to A3 first well
this is the reason why Rook captures on
D6 uh giving back the exchange Knight
captures we have King captures and it
seems you're going to lose the E7 Pawn
as well but no now comes Pawn to B4
that's the the the good stuff and also
uh here a few moves ago you you probably
were thinking after Bishop captures on
A7 can you trap the bishop no you can't
because B4 traps the black Bishop on A5
so here uh B4 attacks the bishop Bishop
to C7 and now Bishop to C5 check defends
the uh D7 Pawn so you have to play A3 in
order to be able to play play Pawn to B4
in order to be able to give a check and
defend the pawn on E7 that's how chess
Works uh most of the time uh so King to
C6 we have Rook to C1 now threatening
all sorts of discoveries King to D1 and
now Bishop to D4 offering your own
Bishop for the bishop on C7 and it's not
great even if you try Bishop captures on
G3 white will just play Bishop captures
on F6 so you don't really gain anything
by that and if you play King captures
and just trade Bishops uh then B5 okay
you sort of stop the expansion of the
Queens side pawns but now after King F3
and King to D5 you will run into a check
and the the B5 Pawn Falls then the A and
B Pawn uh will run forward freely so
Rook captures on E7 it's the best way to
go Bishop captures on F6 and now Rook to
F7 we have Rook to C5 with check King to
E4 and now Bishop captures and G5 so now
you are up two pawns and uh well it's
going to be very very hard to hold
Bishop to B6 attacks The Rook Rook B5 we
have Bishop to D4 now Bishop to d8 uh
trying to trade off the the remaining
piece with Bishop to B6 so Rook to D7
and now Bishop to B6 of course you have
to avoid the trade you are down two
pawns so all trades favor the the the
side with more material King to H3 Now
Pawn to H5 we have Rook to C5 and now
Rook to D3 going after the A3 Pawn but
just Bishop to C7 so you don't really
gain anything because if you if you
trade here and capture on E3 Rook captur
on B7 and again you up two pawns and you
have a pass B Pawn you're just going to
push it to Victory also you're probably
going to win the H5 Pawn so depending on
how black plays he will win this way or
the other so Bishop to D4 attacks The
Rook now comes Rook captures on H5 and
first Rook to C3 attacking the bishop on
C7 Bishop to D6 and only now Vincent
grabs the A3 Pawn we have Bishop to C5
trying to trade off the remaining
material Bishop D5 of course Vincent
cannot afford this Rook to H7 and pawn
to B5 but uh you cannot defend it
forever Rook B7 King to F3 and now Rook
captures on B5 here Vincent played Rook
to A1 maybe hoping for some King to H4
so maybe The Rook goes behind the pawn
tries to attack it but it doesn't really
work here Rook A5 was played and he was
in this position on move 55 that Vincent
kimer resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here you're
simply down too much material your
opponent has three points you have zero
and uh okay you you could play something
like Rook H1 let's say but then you kick
away the black king king D4 you go Rook
B3 you start advancing your past B Pawn
and that's pretty much a Sol but surely
white will definitely win this uh when
you're up three pawns it's just too much
of a difference to to to even try
something uh so yeah after Rook to A5
kimer resigned and another excellent
victory for Andre esenko who after eight
rounds of this year's feed Grand Swiss
Still Remains undefeated uh and uh these
are the standings for the moment so you
can see that uh four players are on six
out of eight and they are Andrea speno
vid GTI Fabiano Carana and Bogan Daniel
deak uh so uh we'll see what happens in
round nine uh some of the pairings from
round nine if you guys are interested
let me just check real
quickly uh some of the pairings from
round nine who will meet who on on the
top boards so Fabiano corono will face B
and Daniel d as they are also the
leaders and yeno will face the other
leader vidit Gujarati so those are the
four leaders and they will face each
other then you have Nakamura chaparo
fedos erigi Mak larana kuzubov seian
bakro
pryan syaro Vash and kimer will be
facing niin so yeah very nicely done
also makulu really gaining a lot of
rating points uh uh he's already up to
world number 14 on the live ratings list
uh so you know if he if he does really
well he might even be yeah okay then he
he will have to win like maybe 10 more
points uh or to enter the the world top
10 uh but yeah if he does really well he
might be able to do it so yeah that's
the game really hope you guys enjoyed it
and a bit of extra info on the standings
and on the on the ratings hope you
enjoyed that as well uh I would like to
thank chess beats leue Roman manini Sams
joh Tes Farm marwin Sparrow and ghard
hlan for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions but mostly covering the feed
the grand Swiss until it finishes uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day